you keep will prosper and has prospered
when it positions itself in the common
sense center of British politics as we
did with our excellent election
manifesto and when Nigel Farage leads it
from the center of the party or perhaps
just to the right of center of the party
you know people who want to get rid of
the National Health Service or
liberalized gun laws or whatever other
US imports they want to pedal for their
own agendas should go and set up a party
to push that line and see how they get
on because I predict it won't be well
now can I go back to my fundamental
point is our duty in you Kip everyone in
you kit from the leader downwards to
maximize our chances of winning an EU
referendum in two years time or perhaps
even less we have to be inclusive we
have to bring in groups of
non-traditional supporters we have to
reach out we have to be team players in
that wider Euroskeptic items being
absolutely in the next couple of years
Patrick airplane sorry to interrupt is
clear that you have a problem with the
AIDS around Nigel Farage but what about
Nigel Farage himself should he stand
down do you want a leadership contest no
no he was a lectin unopposed I think it
was last September's for a four-year
term I would much rather there'd be none
of this hiatus about leadership at all
and that would have been my advice
tonight Randy sort if afford it he what
he said he should run for the boy
attorney should serve the four-year term
he should lead us into the referendum
campaign it should recapture the
optimistic cheerful reaching out you
know cheeky Nigel Farage that you know
such an inspiration to me and I believe
he can but I believe there are a type of
people around him who I won't name but
influencing him in the wrong direction
well you know I won't dignify them by
naming them but you know they have been
given far too much sway far too much
influence and have treated certain very
loyal party staffers absolutely
abysmally and someone needs to call time
on them so let's be clear those are the
people I have an issue with in terms of
their conduct and advice to the part
leader you know I am a loyal supporter
of Nigel Farage's leadership I just want
to get it back to how it was before this
group came to prominence okay